[Music]
eleven years after Chris Redfield
survived the munchin incident he finds
himself in Africa for resident evil 5
chris is now a part of the BS double-a a
bioterrorism security assessment
Alliance it just rolls off the tongue
and rendevouz in Africa with counterpart
Sheva Alomar they are tasked with
pretending Ricardo Irving who is
attempting to sell a bioweapon on the
black market they quickly discover the
locals are infected with a similar
parasite after Dawes in Resident Evil 4
Chris notices an image of his former
partner Jill Valentine and now the game
decides to inform us that Jill died
taking down Albert Wesker a few years
ago you know I'm just one of those throw
away pieces of information about two of
the most important characters in
Resident Evil history anyway we are
informed that Jill is still alive so
Chris changes his priorities to find his
old partner good old she ever comes on
for the ride - while searching for Jill
Chris finds Ricardo Irving and he and
Sheva corner him feeling like his only
option is to fight urban inject himself
with a parasite variant of las Plagas
and become the hulking great octopus
thing she ever and Chris don't mess
around and kill Irving but only after he
gives them precious intel on a nearby
cave our heroes locate the cave which is
home to the flowers that created the
original progenitor virus to make the
story a little mark on volute 'add the
surrounding area is filled with try sell
paraphernalia and try sell other
companies who funds the BSAA
yes the organization that Chris and
Sheva work for with a little further
delving it becomes apparent that try
still have continued on browsers
research and run a secret laboratory
filled to the brim with live specimens
and test subjects Chris Lockett gills
capsule but of course it's empty the
revelations keep coming at Rice LCE or
Excel a G on it is in cahoots with
Albert Wesker so yes both Jill and
Wesker are still alive a flashback
informs of the Oswell Spencer one of the
founding members of umbrella created the
Wesker children in an attempt to fulfill
his desire to be a god Albert Wesker is
said to be the sole survivor of this
project
Wesker does not take too kindly to the
fact that he was manufactured and
murders the man he once considered a
father Wesker plans to infect the entire
globe with the latest super bio weapon
or Boris he thought only a select few
people will survive along the human race
to prosper by weeding out the weaker
individual your Valentine is revealed to
be one of Wesker's lackeys due to a
mind-control amulet which is buried in
her chest Chris and Sheva remove it and
Jill wakes up from her nightmare to buy
him more time Wesker decides to infect
Axela with the Ouroboros virus and she
becomes a giant tentacled beast which of
course is defeated by our hero Jill
informed krysta there is only one way to
beat Wesker and it's to over infect him
with the virus they act on Jill's words
to mixed results but Wesker attempts to
flee in a bobber primed with Oliver off
missiles Chris and Sheva bring down the
plate in a volcano of all places Wesker
is now in full rage mode and muted and
this is where the final battle is held
Chris and Sheva defeat Wesker but he
will not stay dead just in the nick of
time
Jill shows up and rescues the dynamic
duo who finally kill Wesker using twin
rocket launchers
here's Oh
you
exactly it is Wesker really dead I'm
sure we'll find out soon enough but
that's it
that's resid evil five in three minutes
do is a favour press subscribe bloody
hard work that thanks again
I'm Adam from Playstation grenades and
I'll see you next time
[Music]